[Music]
farming in america could not exist
without john deere
[Music]
i don't care where you are
in the rural parts of america there's
farmland and you're inevitably going to
see green tractors
specifically in the midwest where people
who've had deer machines for generations
say that their family bleed green it's
really to that extent
but john deere's tractors aren't the
only thing bleeding green
john deere is on pace to have its most
profitable year ever
john deere is forecast to make about 7.7
billion dollars in the fiscal year 2021.
that would be a record
but while john deere shareholders and
executives could not be happier john
deere has been in a battle on two fronts
between a massive union strike from
upset workers and a legal battle with
farmers concerning equipment repairs
called right to repair john deere must
convince their customers and their
employees that they care about more than
just profits
this is the breakdown
[Music]
[Music]
there's a saying that you'll hear either
dear say or other people say if farmers
are profiting deer is profiting
and deer wants to do everything they can
to
make those farmers a lot more profitable
since the pandemic hit in 2020 and
millions of americans sheltered in place
buying nothing but groceries both john
deere and farmers became even more
essential in feeding america and both
profited a great deal as a result
because the machines they make are
essential to an industry that has to
provide an essential product for
consumers not in the united states but
across the globe
john deere's profits during the pandemic
are eye-popping and that wealth has
spread out to executives like ceo john
may who brought in 15.6 million dollars
in 2020 a 160
raise and according to our bloomberg
data he's going to make about 30 million
for the 2021 fiscal year so you're
talking about almost 10 million more for
the ceo earnings
shareholders also saw their slice of the
pie in part because of john deere's
stock buybacks
buybacks are a piece of financial
engineering by a company to repurchase
shares of its own stock to reduce the
number of shares in the market which in
turn creases the ownership stake for the
shareholders the stock buybacks for them
have been significant so in the past 12
months they bought back 1.9 billion
dollars in stock and they bought back
716 million alone in their fiscal third
quarter of 2021
one group who thought they were not
sharing in that wealth
john deere factory workers
so the optics are obviously looking bad
for the company now that a labor strike
has broken out among
part of their workforce
during this boom time dear offered their
workers a 5 pay increase
that's when over 10 000 united auto
workers who worked for john deere went
on strike i had one person in particular
say our ceo is about to make 10 million
dollars more
for this year than he did last year
the company is seeing earnings go to
records the stock price is surging and
yet we're the group who during the past
recession and past down economic cycles
in the farming industry
we took cuts
after the union turned down two
contracts john deere was finally able to
meet their demands in late november
which doubled raises and improved
pensions for union members
those employees that are represented by
the uaw are immensely valuable employees
to us we're super proud of where the
contract ended up it's groundbreaking in
a lot of ways both from from near-term
wage increases as well as the retirement
medical benefits that it offers it's
super helpful to understand how the work
is done in the factories what the
opportunities are to make improvements
for whatever the operation happens to be
to make the lives of those that are
doing that work better
so while john deere workers fought and
won their battle to see the profits the
company has brought in over the past two
years farmers are still in their own
fight with deer when it comes to
repairing their own equipment
[Music]
so a lot of farms our size use a variety
of technology we use old technology we
use new technology
my name is tom brandt and you are
currently in plymouth nebraska i am a
farmer and also a state senator
i represent district 32 fillmore there
jefferson saline and southwestern
lancaster counties here in nebraska
the state of nebraska's agriculture is
the fourth largest ag powerhouse in the
nation
we feed way more people with the food we
produce than just the 1.96 million
people here in the state of nebraska
the farm that you're on today is a farm
that's common to southeast nebraska
we rotate corn and soybeans
it takes hundreds of thousands of
dollars to operate a small farm like
this our margins are razor thin
farming is an industry where we buy
retail and we sell wholesale
while the principles of farming remain
the same the equipment used to farm has
changed dramatically
this is a 1952 alice chalmers wd
this is a style of tractor i grew up on
in the 60s and 70s
this tractor
has not
started
for two months
it's tough
and it works and this is what american
farm equipment used to be like
[Music]
farming equipment from both john deere
and their major competitors has become
much more technologically sophisticated
in the past two decades
a little after 2000 tractors changed
from being strictly just a power and
source and got to be a lot more
computerized
now they're all basically drive by wire
systems where there's no physical
connection between any of our controls
in the tractor except a piece of wire
and every generation tractor sense is
even more computerized
it surprises people every day how
technologically sophisticated the
equipment is whether that's you know
gnss satellite guidance
in our equipment or whether it's the
digital information that comes off those
equipment that helps make customers
enable them to make better decisions
every day
this is the main computer screen right
here
it can show us moisture it can show us
yield
it can show us the various components on
the combine
20 years ago our irrigated corn probably
yielded 150 60 bushels to the acre this
last crop we just harvested we did 250
bushels to the acre
so
if your crops are gaining yield 40
over 10 or 20 years you're going to need
bigger faster equipment to harvest it
and those bigger faster machines have
increased productivity an estimated 1.4
percent per year over the past 70 years
and u.s farmers now produce an average
corn yield of about 175 bushels an acre
and then
the really valuable information that
starts to move markets is what the
harvest looks like so now
one of these enormous harvesters will
tell in real time through this modem
under the farmer's rear end back to deer
and who knows where to goldman sachs
maybe
exactly how much corn or wheat is being
harvested on that farm acreage at that
moment
it's really staggering
we get a lot more done in a day we can
work longer hours especially with the
auto steer auto guidance systems we can
get a lot more hours in we're not tired
at the end of the day so the efficiency
factor is great when it works
unfortunately like all electronics
it doesn't always work
and that's where there's a catch
while the technology in a john deere
tractor or combine makes farming easier
than ever before there are very real
concerns from some farmers when it comes
to repairing that equipment because as
of right now they can't
john deere and other agricultural
machinery companies won't let farmers
fix their own equipment without a
licensed mechanic
for deer and its dealerships parts and
services are three to six times more
profitable than sales of original
equipment according to company filings
historically farmers have always
repaired their own equipment
farmers love to tinker i will grant that
we all like to change with our equipment
and we all modify our equipment
the right to repair
gets down to the nuts and bolts that
currently farmers don't have access to
the computer systems on their farm
equipment doesn't matter whether it's
green john deere or it's red case
or agcos they're all proprietary they
won't let us in on that
the thing that you fix on the tractor
isn't necessarily like a moving part it
may be something that has to be fixed in
the software or like hitting a reset
button for your computer
we've had a few cases where we get an
error code on the panel and it is
basically you look it up and it says
call your dealer
so the dealer has to come out and they
plug their computer into the tractor and
they have to diagnose what the problem
is
we have operators who have had computer
glitches during planning
they have a newer tractor they have a
newer planner it happens on a friday
they got to wait till monday to get it
fixed they've lost two and a half days
if they were given access to the
operating system they knew what they had
to do to repair that
and there are literally billions of
dollars at stake for john deere when it
comes to repairs
they make a lot of their money in the
dealerships from parts and repair
because frankly they have a monopoly and
that monopoly has been
significantly enhanced by
the software controls in the modern
tractor no one else can work on them
annual parts sales increased 23 to 6.8
billion dollars from 2013 to 2020 while
deer's total agricultural equipment
sales fell 20 to 22.3 billion dollars
so there's very real money at stake when
it comes to repair
if a right to repair law allowed parts
and services markets to compete it could
be a huge blow to a vital income stream
for the company
the farmers of the world say we've been
repairing these things forever farmers
know how to fix things know how to keep
things working in the fields and by
denying is that you're essentially
taking away
a kind of birthright john deere is also
the target of a potential federal class
action lawsuit alleging antitrust
violations tied to its repair policies
john deere declined to comment on the
litigation but said it meets company
commitments to provide parts information
and software to owners of its equipment
[Music]
however there is precedent when it comes
to right to repair
the best way of explaining the right to
repair is to go back to automobiles
as automobiles were built with more and
more software and chips it became
more and more difficult for the average
car owner to fix their car because the
software you didn't have the tools to do
that
so in 2012 the state of massachusetts
introduced a right to repair bill on
light cars and trucks they were the only
state in the nation to do that and what
that did is that opened the flood gates
and
made it possible for third-party
mechanics the mom and pop to
access
and repair
all those vehicles
i can tell you locally we have a
situation just like that last january
of 2021 based on the fact that the farm
bureau membership overwhelmingly wanted
to see a right to repair bill we
introduced one
that bill called lb 543 was voted in
favor 176 to 1 by the farmers yet right
now that bill sits in committee because
it required amendments to only reference
repairing farm equipment and not other
electronics like iphones computers and
televisions
our position is fairly straightforward
we believe that farmers have the right
to repair their equipment where we draw
the line is the right to modify and it
generally involves the embedded software
that we put on the machines
agricultural equipment is less like
consumer electronics than it is really
like
aviation right you wouldn't want just
anybody fixing and repairing software on
an airplane because there is a safety
component to it in the same way you know
i think a tractor going down the highway
is a fairly comparable situation that's
really where our efforts are best spent
to try to make sure that people
understand the ramifications and the
risks associated with the conversations
that are currently happening in the
space
[Music]
while farmers are waiting for a ruling
to be made on right to repair some are
taking matters into their own hands by
using gray market technology to run
diagnostics on their own equipment when
you rebel against a technological
barrier you hack it
and there are a number of farmers who've
availed themselves of john deere repair
and diagnostic software
from places like hong kong and other
markets where things are sold without
the proper licenses it's the software
black market or in this case it's really
a gray market
right now the right to repair is still
moving forward
but its future is anything but certain
currently lb 543 is sitting in committee
and we chose to have it stay there for
one year to allow all parties to give us
some input on this
and it's pretty much been crickets
but the hue and cry out here in the
country is getting louder
people want more regulation or at least
the opportunity to control their own
destiny they don't like seeing it in the
hands of big corporations
we'll keep working at it until we get it
accomplished
i'm not afraid of a fight
i haven't met a farmer yet that's not
afraid of a fight
so we'll state our piece
and see what we can get done
[Music]
you